what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or prom and welcome back to
another bleach video on the channel one
of the most exciting aspects of the show
is the wide range of powerful characters
with unique abilities that we get to see
in action from captains of the Soul
Society to the Espada to the stern
Ritter the show is full of formidable
opponents for Ichigo and his friends to
face so who are the strongest characters
in Bleach well that's what we're going
to explore today we'll be looking at
characters like sosuke Eisen who
possesses incredible intelligence and a
Mastery of both swordsmanship and keto
Kenpachi is a rocky the captain of the
11th division who is renowned for his
raw strength and fighting skills and of
course many more we'll also be examining
the abilities and weaknesses of these
characters and how they stack up against
one another whether you're a long time
fan of bleach or new to the series you
will not want to miss this video so
let's get into it now if you do enjoy
these bleach videos on the channel and
you'd like to see more do you know what
to do smash that like button as it
really helps us out with that YouTube
algorithm if you haven't already make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications we're trying to reach 2
million subscribers here on the channel
and we'd love for you to be a part of
that Journey with us you can also follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime or
Pro and now without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all first up
is retsu unahana a former captain of the
fourth division she was the best healer
in the entire soul society and one of
the oldest and most seasoned go Thai 13
captains for those of you who don't know
about unohana this placement will come
as a surprise because she was mostly
used or only ever depicted as a Healer
in the series just to be clear there are
definite spoilers below now we didn't
really get to witness how powerful and
terrifying unohana was until the
Thousand-Year blood War Arc kempachi
Zaraki captain of the 11th Vision was to
learn zonjutsu from her the two fought
her the death in an effort to impart
this strength building knowledge into
kampachi in this battle we learn a few
things in the past unohana was the most
evil criminal in the entire soul society
when assembling the gotai 13 Yamamoto
actually went out of his way to find her
and she ended up becoming the first
kempachi and captain of the 11th
division now while on a mission she saw
a boy who attacked her at first sight
the two then engaged in combat that boy
was none other than a young kempachis
Iraqi kempachi acknowledged that during
their battle he experienced fear for the
first time he wanted more since their
first fight since he enjoyed the
sensation of being in this fight with
her for kempachi to say this it would be
clear just how formidable of an opponent
una Hana is we got to experience this
new side of unohana and the incredible
power she possessed in the fight between
the two in the Thousand-Year blood War
Arc which was simply fantastic now her
Bankai was one of her great Mysteries
she was unfortunately killed before we
could really see what it was capable of
so sadly not much is known about it we
only know a few things like the fact
that when her Bankai is discharged the
blade of her zompoc toe transforms into
a thick dark red liquid that flows all
around her we think it's blood but there
is no proof of that her bankai's liquid
resembles a very potent acid with enough
strength to melt an opponent to the Bone
aside from that I believe there was
still a lot more to her than we ever saw
but based on what we did learn about her
unohana is obviously very well deserving
of her place on the list and before we
move on I have to say that bleach is
certainly not sure of its list of best
girls as a bit of a waifu connoisseur
myself I am saddened and shocked that
the girls in this show aren't up there
with the most powerful and bleach as
unohana is the only girl on this list
next up is the former president of the
Shinigami Research Institute and the
former captain of the 12th Division
kisuke urahara and he is one impressive
dude perhaps the smartest character in
the entire series urahara is an expert
tactician and strategist who is also a
talented inventor who has created some
of the most extraordinary and potent
weapons the most lethal of which is of
course the hokyoku he is not just
intelligent he is also a specialist in
both unarmed and armed combat as well as
having vast knowledge of Keto Goose an
achievement that tells a thousand words
about this man's utter Brilliance is the
fact that his Mastery of Keto has not
only enabled him to perform high level
keto but also to invent some high level
keto too currently urahara is considered
one of the strongest captains or
characters overall in the entire series
thanks to his zombok toe as especially
his bonkai his Bankai conjures a crimson
clad giant lady who grants kisuke the
power to tear apart and re-stitch
anything he so chooses including the
terrain he's fighting on his muscle
strength or even his own injuries as we
saw in his battle with Askin no one is
Invincible of course yet because of the
might of his bonkai orahara comes quite
near that as a result it should go
without saying that urahara is not only
one of the series most significant
characters but also one of its strongest
earning him a spot on the list of the
series most strongest characters let's
get our Quincy on as uru Ishida is next
up at the beginning of bleach earlier
Ashira isn't all that powerful in terms
of power scaling he is actually far
behind that of series protagonist Ichigo
Kurosaki the character Arc of uriu in
Bleach has numerous twists and turns
including a period where he entirely
lost all of his skills although he was
significantly underpowered and
unappreciated at times during the series
is by the end of the series he had
developed into much more than just one
of each ghost Sidekicks the Quincy King
yuha intentionally chose earlier to
succeed in when he finally made his
return after centuries the identity of
ulio a Half-Blood Quincy who survived
yuha's attempt on his life as an infant
was a very shocking Revelation this was
done so that the Quincy King could
regain his powers
udio was the only Half-Blood Quincy who
was unaffected making him a very special
case even amongst full-blood quinces
after receiving the anesthesis from yuha
urio had a significant increase in
ryatsu making him significantly more a
formidable opponent with the aid of his
ability anesthesis uriu is able to
choose any two Targets and fully undo
anything that has happened between them
for instance if Urdu had suffered severe
injuries while engaging in anime he
could select both himself and the enemy
as targets and undo what had just
occurred this would heal him while
dishing out the damage he received to
the anime this ability certainly gives
urio more than enough to earn an entry
on this list
the captain of the 11th Division and the
absolute brutal force kempachi Zaraki
comes next where should we begin with
kampachi well he's a true warrior and a
master of combat when I say master of
combat I truly mean Master since he
thrives on Battle his only motivation is
to fight and get stronger thus having a
lot of experience is one of the
byproducts of that way of life the other
captains frequently keep him at a
distance which I feel makes him look
like more of an outsider amongst the go
type 13 and although the other captains
are extremely powerful they have
selected words like Supernatural and
unmeasurable to characterize the iraqi's
strength when he was younger and engaged
in combat with unohana before becoming a
division Commander she admitted that
despite being the last one standing she
felt that he was stronger and more
qualified to become kempachi Kenpachi
has always had a latent ability but he
never bothered to make an effort to use
it because he was afraid that if he did
his battles would end far too quickly so
in order to engage in his passion of
combat for as long as possible his eye
patch seals his overflowing and
tremendous spiritual strength but he has
removed it during a few fires and man
was it truly a sight to behold when he
did so almost impossible to stop the man
when the eye patch is removed now he
will turn into a Berserker demon when he
activates his Bankai insane strength
here but at the expense of his own sense
of Reason his bunkai also fits this
similar sealed motive of the eye patch
kempachi occupies a rank on our list of
strongest bleed characters because he is
so tremendously strong that only a
select few opponents can match him at
his Peak now we have also done a full
video explaining just how strong
kempachi is definitely give that video a
watch after this one to get a more
in-depth look at this absolute
Powerhouse next up is Captain shunsui
Kyoko of the first division who is also
the current commander of the gotai 13.
shinsui is what you might refer to as
the toll package yes all the characters
on this list share characteristics such
as being experts with a weapon in common
but soon sweet is superior than almost
everyone else in aspects and should not
be underestimated due to his
overwhelming strength it's almost hard
to beat him in battle now both his
zompokto's appearance and personality
set it apart from other zonbokto of the
Soul Reapers here's zonpokto's
personality only manifests during combat
and will only permit shinsui to use all
of his strength only when it is in the
mood for it this is a great example of
his strength if you needed one shinsuke
used only his she-kai to defeat the top
ranked aspart as Stark this is both a
demonstration of shunsui's skills and a
nod to the deadly powers of his bunkai
which shoots me itself avoids using
unless absolutely necessary an aura
surrounds shunsui when he unleashes his
Bankai this Aura Alters how a person
perceives their surroundings making
everyone caught in its range-filled
Despair and sadness shinsui does not
want to gamble with innocent or Ally
forces who may be trapped within its
boundaries since his bonkai produces
mental Despair and the repercussions of
death to everyone and everything within
its range we can be certain that
shinsuke Kyoko is one of the greatest
Shinigami in existence because of his
bonkai and how powerful he is otherwise
do you hard shoot Starfall was the most
menacing of the exceptionally strong
foes that the Thousand-Year blood War
Arc presented Lily Barrow of the first
of Utah's shrifted minions is very proud
of himself and his enormous Arsenal Lily
Barrow has demonstrated that Quincy's
have just as much potential as Soul
Reapers in Bleach Lily is an egotistical
man who considers himself to be the
closest thing to God being the first
Quincy to ever receive shrift from yuha
in Bleach Lily burrow assumed command of
the shoot star for which was of course
yuha's own Elite guard using his rifle
and his power the x-axis he will
undoubtedly hear and obliterate his
Target thanks to his amazing Precision
he is the most well-known Rifleman in
the series never missing his Mark and no
amount of defensive strategy can really
stop his attacks this is because Lily
Compares through everything because
nothing is strong enough to resist or
block his power he is given Arcane
skills like teleportation intangibility
and Hyper regime Generation by his Vol
standing also known as jiliel he is the
only Stern Ritter who can perform a
secondary Vol standing this is similar
to ukiora and his Segunda atapa Lily
produces enough power so that he is able
to blast bursts of energy that can
completely annihilate entire cities in
the blink of an eye from everything
you've just heard there's no question
that this guy has to be on this list of
bleach's strongest characters
next up we have another Stern Ritter and
that is none other than Thor himself
Gerard Valkyrie one of the most
formidable combatants in yuha's Quincy
Army as well as one of the most powerful
characters overall in Bleach is without
a doubt here Gerard Valkyrie Gerard
Valkyrie is not only one of you hard
shooting star for but also the heart of
the Soul King Gerard's physical strength
is his most incredible feat due to his
physical power he also has incredible
resilience to fatal attacks Gerard is a
ruthless individual who takes great
pride in his abilities when numerous
captains and lieutenants approached him
Gerard ordered them to come at him right
away because they wouldn't be able to
defeat him in a one-on-one fight he
possesses a natural ability known as the
miracle which enables him to Prevail in
the face of impossible challenges his
skill grows stronger the more
challenging the circumstances appear to
be he can transform any physical harm
dealt to him in into increases in size
and might so if any opponent is
fortunate enough to strike him they'll
probably wish that they hadn't and if
that wasn't enough he had the ability to
grow wings and take to the air as well
Gerard can give shape to his own and
other people's thoughts feelings and
desires using the Miracle's power
another one of the Miracles amazing
skills is that it can help him change
the odds in his favor by probability
manipulation Gerard Valkyrie is an
absolute beast and without a doubt
worthy of a space in this list
next up we have jog run is the leader of
the stone Ritter also known as the stern
Ritter Grand Master jogram is yuha's
most loyal subordinate making him the
ideal choice to serve as the latter's
advisor jogrim is also second in command
which says a lot about how powerful a
Quincy he is in reference to drug room's
power of giving and sharing yuha refers
to him as his other half now Joe
Graham's powered the balance is
unquestionably a powerful shrift that
absorbs and transfers bad luck in other
words he is able to hand his opponents
their own bad luck jogram can take the
bad things that happen in his area of
influence and then distribute them to
people who have themselves been
fortunate the balance is very similar to
urdu's power that we mentioned earlier
in the video in a similar way to uria's
Abella says if jogrim were to sustain
bad damage he can then transfer that
harm to his intended target who is
benefiting from Good Fortune by
combining their Good Fortune with their
bad fortune this act restores the scan
scale's proper balance now the sacrifice
Shield or friend Shield is dragon's
Spirit weapon jogan can make this Shield
which is both incredibly strong and
solid materialize on his left arm by
using reishi instead of functioning as a
typical Shield which you would expect to
prevent incoming attacks from his
opponents jogrim's Shield actually
absorbs his bad luck including the
injuries that were stated above jogram
is also the only other Quincy after
yuhad that has the ability to transfer
his own power to another Quincy he is
also unlike the other Quincy as he can't
naturally absorb reishi from his
environment but instead he is able to
provide reishi to others around him
jogrom also possesses yuhaz the almighty
power drugum can employ the might of the
almighty at night when yuha goes to
sleep but only at that time jogram can
predict the future thanks to this power
but unlike yuhar he is unable to change
it super interesting character this one
and definitely one that you don't want
to come up against in a fight
camera you saw Yamamoto the captain of
the first Division and former commander
of the gotai 13 is up next Yamamoto is a
guy who you just have no chance of
defeating because of his next level
power as a matter of fact he commanded
the go type 13 for more than a thousand
years because no other Shinigami could
match his strength during his fight with
shunsui kiroko and juiciro ukitake
sheunsues Lieutenant Nana now was
rendered unconscious by just his riyatsu
it is very clear that even his spiritual
pressure is potent enough to unnerve and
immobilize most people he even used the
oldest songpaktou ryajin Shaka which was
so strong that it was more powerful than
all the other zampokto in the soul
Society put together a single slash of
ryajin jaka can turn anyone or anything
into ashes now despite his Advanced age
he was a master of everything here
shikai and bunkai have crazy power they
either burn or cut everything in half or
the Flames they emit either burn or cut
everything completely out of existence
it's insane if the Flames they generate
don't sound extremely overpowered to you
I'm not sure what else would his Bankai
also has several nasty features one of
which lets him call the dead to his side
he not only has the ability to summon
people he has defeated but he also has
the choice of who it is that he summons
as a result this powerful character is
able to defeat anyone he chooses before
calling them to battle beside him
needless to say oh man Yama is a guy you
do not mess with you run away if you can
moving on to the captain of the zero
division ichibe ichibe was introduced in
the later episodes of Bleach but became
more popular than most characters in the
series ichibe is an incredibly strong
Shinigami and is the leader of the zero
division or the royal guard who are
tasked with protecting the soul king and
the royal family each Bay becomes
happier when he resolves to kill someone
but he spares the lives of his opponents
in a condescending manner interestingly
as well many terminology in the soul
Society including Bankai zompokto and
shikai were created by ichibe he was the
first Shinigami whose zompokto underwent
a transformation and he also learned the
names of every zompoc toe hishikai's
unique skill is the ability to swing his
blade which then releases an ink that
causes whatever it covers to lose its
name and along with it its powers the
blade of his zompoc toe assumes the
shape of a white brush when his Bankai
is activated ichibe can write kanji on a
target's body to change or add to their
name before being struck by the ink of
his zombok toe he can alter that
person's Power by doing this in other
words whatever he chooses to write on a
person they become powerful as that
thing he scribbled black and on yuha and
he got as weak as that of a black ant
all his former strength power and skills
had been diminished to the level of a
little insect for a very short period of
time ichibe's powers are just incredible
when you think about them and that is
why he ranks so high on this list
Ichigo Kurosaki the protagonist of the
series he advances from being one of the
weakest Soul Reapers to outclassing most
of them Ichigo is beyond a doubt one of
the most powerful characters in this
series now that he has control thanks to
his Mastery of the sword Hollow forms
Quincy bloodline and a variety of other
skills and powers that he's picked up
along the way each group like we heard
that possesses a very complex concoction
of abilities including the iconic Hollow
Mask setos full brings blunt van shikai
and bunkai Ichigo is just the Classic
shirt and protagonist and his strength
knows no bounds and constantly picks up
new skills during every Arc of bleach he
was able to defeat Elite captains like
kempachi Zaraki and biochia kuchki
despite having far less combat
experience throughout the series his
biggest asset proved to be his
unwavering resolve to win Ichigo is a
person who prioritizes protecting the
defenseless he will put himself in Risk
to Aid others whether they are members
of his family close friends or even
total strangers regardless of what might
happen to him he's a hero through and
through each gobe is a substitute Soul
Reaper yet in a relatively short period
of time he has outperformed the majority
of the characters in this list in skill
and fighting he is one of the strongest
most admired characters in Bleach
because of his heart and perseverance as
well as his abundance of spiritual power
we also made an hour-long video doing a
deep dive into all of ichigo's powers
and abilities we will link that video in
the description below so definitely
check that out if you'd like to look at
ichigo's powers and abilities in a lot
more detail
third slot goes to sosuke Eisen a former
captain of the fifth division who after
betraying the soul Society essentially
acquired god-like status most characters
in the story are unable to realize the
extent of eisen's spiritual power Eisen
was very much an immortal entity that
could take down any and everything that
he desired I'm sure even a deity
wouldn't have been out of his reach he
of course was one of the go ties 13's
top military thinkers as well as one of
its top Swordsmen eisen's mind is almost
as strong as his physical mind which is
what makes him so terrifying Eisen is a
genius and his intelligence is unrivaled
however he employs his intelligence for
deceit Eisen is incredibly cunning and
has betrayed a great number of people
who have trusted him now the easiest way
to comprehend his power is to examine
the battles he has engaged and prevailed
in Eisen basically defeated the entire
go tide 13 as well as the Visage in a
fight with them if that wasn't enough to
persuade you can consider the time the
Eisen defeated the formidable team of
ashin Kurosaki yoruichi hoyan and kisuke
urahara and one if it wasn't for Ichigo
giving up his spiritual abilities to use
mugetsu Eisen would have undoubtedly
gone on to conquer or Wipe Out the
entire world so if it comes as no
surprise that Eisen is so high up on
this list in second place we have none
other than yuha bar the soul King's son
yuha is incomparable to anybody else in
Bleach he would have easily and
effectively put a stop to the bleach
Universe if it wasn't for one slip up
it's no secret that yuha who has been
imprisoned for almost 1 000 years is one
of the strongest characters in the
entire series his perfect Fusion of
talent power and nullification skills
future sight and intelligence make him a
nightmarish foe yuhar possesses
Incredible strength his ability to take
advantage of other people's skills
draining them dry and killing them is
possibly his most terrifying quality
this implies that there is no limit to
how powerful he could have finally
become his skills include sanct Bogan
the ability to summon a cute bow with
enough power to propel him back to his
Palace if need be and then there's blood
a Quincy method that grants him
superhuman abilities moreover he has the
power to summon monsters with one eye
resembling bats that will attack any
Shinigami in the area the icing on the
cake is that he is incredibly Elusive
and has the ability to instantly move
long distances thanks to his ability to
build portals now the future can be
altered by yuha's ability the almighty
who can also speed up time in ways that
are advantageous to him the guy is just
absolutely next level on the power scale
and without a doubt the strongest foe
Ichigo and Co has ever come up against
but who is stronger than him well that
title in first place on this list goes
to yuha's father the soul King the soul
King is arguably the most powerful
entity to have ever existed in the
bleach Universe being the ruler of the
Soul society and a God the soul King was
the center of existence now humans and
Spirits once coexisted when there was
only one real world suddenly the
soul-eating hollows appeared and began
to kill humans Spirits the soul King
arrived and began to slaughter all the
hollows in order to defend the world
unfortunately eliminating Hollows caused
the Earth to become unstable the first
group of Shinigami who would later
become the ancestors of bleach's five
noble families the shioin clan kuchiki
Clan Shiba Clan tsunashiro Clan and
kasamoji Clan all stopped his hunting
the human world Waco Mundo and the Soul
Society were all established using the
soul King's Powers which they managed to
acquire the soul King now resides at the
Seoul Palace and to defend the soul King
Palace and royal families he could
produce an altashinigami known as Royal
Guards using his Oaken bestowman
abilities he has the Almighty which
gives him the power to predict or change
the future and the three worlds or
Realms were made by the almighty being
the world of the living the soul society
and Waco Mundo these three worms were
bound Together by The Soul King's
strength he possesses an abundance of
spiritual force and riyatsu which is so
strong that you couldn't even begin to
imagine just how much power that is
again we also made a video going into
more detail on the soul King looking at
his backstory his powers how Ichigo
could have been the next Soul King
himself and more which again is linked
in the video description below for you
to check out and that is it our list of
the strongest characters in all of the
bleach series we certainly hope that you
enjoyed this ranking did you agree with
it would you have listed them
differently would you have added
characters to the list let us know in
the comment section below if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to see more
bleached videos on the channel make sure
to let us know by Smashing that like
button if you haven't made this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
anime abroad videos while you waiting
for the next bleach video to drop on the
channel why not check out this video
where I rank all the bleach captains
from weakest to strongest thanks again
and we can't wait to see you in the next
one till next time